il ya encore beaucoup de gens qui va
falloir mobiliser entre les deux tours
je pense que c'est notre enjeu demain
celui qui sera président de la région
devra être fort du soutien des normands
donc cette mobilisation des
abstentionnistes est très importante et
on voit en tout cas en basse-normandie
que l'autre seul break motif à nous
c'est que quand sera la capitale
régionale avec la liste des remémora et
ça ça doit être un élément de
mobilisation intense je pense que les
les habitants de l'ouest de la normandie
les citoyens doivent comprendre que cet
enjeu là est au dessus coisy de tous les
autres et pour nous c'est vraiment le
discours que nous allons tenir entre les
deux tours on comprendre que les destins
aussi d'autres capitales régionales est
en jeu et derrière si ce n'est pas quand
c'est le dessin la dent m'ont dit
lui-même parce que si on équilibre pas
les forces et les pouvoirs au sein la
normandie c'est le projet normand qu'on
rattrape